has done some very interesting works on
off policy
batch data reinforcement learning
all right thank you very much mondee for
the introduction i'd like to thank
organizers for putting together this
excellent program um i'm i'm i have
learned a lot over the two days of
attending the workshop
um so so today's talk is going to be on
off policy evaluation in particular with
offline data
and no access to to the online
environment
and what's probably different from a
typical study of such problems is that
we're going to be considering
the uniform convergence in this problem
on the
very uh narrow-ish setting but but i
will hope that this
setting will reveal some of the
intricacy of the problem right so this
is going to be based on the joint work
with my student minion
and my collaborator you buy from the uh
salesforce research
yeah so there might be like a subset of
the the people who have heard this talk
at the
uh um the the rl uh theory seminar
um that that has been an excellent uh
platform um so so this talk will
not have anything new so so i'm just
just saying that so that you know
like you can decide whether you want to
leave now all right
so um all right so so um the talk is
going to be about
reinforcement learning obviously and
this one of the hottest topics nowadays
um and i just wanted to point out that
most of the the successful applications
of reinforcement learning uh
are in a scenario where you actually
have have access to a simulator
say in games you can you can run
exploration for as many times as you
want
as long as you have a sufficient amount
of computation
right however in practice what often
happens is that when you want to apply
rl
um like you are you're left with a
situation where you have some legacy
data
that's collected from um like running
other policies or from
human taking actions in the environment
and so on and you don't actually
um is legally allowed to to
operate on the real test environment
so so what can we do okay so so um
but i guess the problem can be broken
down into two parts and and that's
also like the two main topics of today
so that's offline policy evaluation and
offline policy learning so in offline
policy evaluation we
uh we need to say uh work on
evaluating like a given target policy
that's
stated independent to the data and then
design methods to use
offline trajectories as collected by a
login policy called miu and
and and somehow evaluate the value of
this target policy
um and of offline policy learning is a
more challenging task that that would
like to
use the same data to directly identify
the near optimal uh policy uh
pi head start so that the the value of
pi hat
uh star is similar to to the value of pi
star which
corresponds to the optimal policy
globally
okay so so there there are multiple
approaches of doing either of these
tasks and
and and and for connecting the task one
to task two
but the version that we're going to be
taking uh is
is to use like a more global approach of
uniform convergence so by deriving the
uniform
of policy evaluation then that naturally
implies
that we can use any algorithm that works
with the op
estimator to somehow obtain a near
optimal policy
okay so so there are many applications
of this um so what i wanted to highlight
is that in all these applications
um sample efficiency is actually hugely
valued because uh
it's it's important to make sure that
every sample matters and we'd like to
make
uh really design like efficient
algorithm up to constant
uh such that uh we can we can we can we
can leverage all the data that's
available to us in in cases such as
medical treatment
um and and in places where exploration
and actually accessing the testing
environment is costly
uh and this is like really the top
priority
to come up with algorithms that are
statistically efficient that
in the sense that it's not wasting data
on a per instance matter and and
um and martin's talk yesterday have uh
have
motivated this problem quite a bit um um
and and i i'd like to just refer uh
people who haven't seen this talk to
to watch martin's video
all right so uh so here's what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna first spend some time to
talk about the problem set up
and so so we are all on the same page
and then i'm going to talk about
our contribution to the problem of
offline learning reinforcement learning
with both
op and um opl and then i'm gonna
talk about how these two are connected
together and
and through the uniform convergence
serums uh with
several interesting um policy classes of
interest
and and um if time permits i'll end with
some discussion on the technical
components and how we derive this
uniform convergence bond and then share
some open problems with with the group
all right so um so we're going to
consider a very modest
setting so comparing to the previous
talk which is a like the fully general
um scope of the offline learning problem
we're gonna consider
the arguably the narrowest possible
setting
um so that we can we can have talk about
concrete sample complexity and concrete
uh optimal dependence and all the
primary parameters of the problem so
we're gonna be
considering the tabular mdp in a uh
non-stationary or often known as timing
homogeneous setting
and and and to to um explicitly talk
about the
planning horizon we're going to assume
episodic mdp
with a horizon being h
right so so um non-stationarity
says that the transition kernels might
be different
at different time points and the
corresponding policy
and then the expected reward vector are
also going to be different
at each time point so this is just
slightly more general
um and and certainly algorithms
operating in this
setting um um can be applied to the to
the stationary case with
with a loss of factor of h in terms of
the sample complexity
all right um and and their standard
value function index
by pi and index by t because this timing
homogeneous and standard definition of
the q function
the only thing i want to say is that we
also define this
scalar v pi which is a single single
variable
uh single number um description of the
value of a given policy
pi right so the initial state uh is like
arbitrary it's either drawn from some
distribution of
specified as a fixed thing
um the the data so the key difference
from other um
consideration uh other existing studies
of the offline rio is that we're not
assuming access to a generative model
so we we actually have um like in
trajectory
of of executing of rolling out on this
episodic environments
um and and um just like the previous
talk we need to to talk about the
marginal state
action visitations um with the
difference being that now this is
indexed by t right so so we can also
conveniently define this matrix of uh
station transition matrix um given by a
particular policy pipe right so this is
a
sa by i say matrix that we can simply
apply these matrices
um to the state action distributions so
so that we can we can simulate the
markov mixing
um um like dynamics
all right so um just one disclaimer um
so exploration is often the hardest
problem in rll but but
since that we're working with with
offline rl we don't have to deal with
exploration we can simply assume it the
way
right because this is mostly because by
by construction
the logging policy that we use to
collect the data is out of our control
so um so all we can do is to assume some
properties that that is satisfied and
then try to work out
the best bond that it entails us to do
right so the specific assumption that we
make is a somewhat standard one so it's
basically
that the login policy is going to visit
every staging pair
at every uh every time step um and
and as long as there is a policy in the
policy class of interest that we want to
derive uniform convergence
um um like uh has has a
probability that's greater than zero so
it's like a measurability
assumption and and then like in some
sense this is we saw a lot of generality
and you have to assume
some sort of uh um conditions like this
in order to to argue that that you can
identify the optimum policy
okay yeah so so i'm gonna
like start by making two observations on
the high level of the problems of of
policy evaluation and learning
um so um so first of all
i i claim that ope is is essentially a
statistical estimation problem
like it's like even though it is uh
in reinforcement learning and there are
dynamics and so on um
it is it is a standard statistical
estimation problem that we
like to estimate um a single unknown
quantity
uh v pi using the observer's iid data
okay so it's slightly non-trivial due to
the underlying dynamics and due to the
many
nuisance variables that are available
that we have to estimate but but if
all the techniques from from statistical
estimation can be applied here and we
can hope to get statistic efficiency
if we use uh these these techniques
correctly
okay we can either talk about um a high
probability
high probability error bound or we can
talk about the mean square error
as a standard approach in in statistics
um and and yeah hopefully
that's a much easier problem the second
observation that i'm gonna make um
like i don't i don't really have to say
this um because this is already covered
by
by nan from the previous talk so offline
learning is essentially a statistical
learning problem okay without online
access to the environment
so you are using iid samples of n copies
so they are somewhat structured but
they're iit samples
um and and and you're given a policy
class or a hypothesis
class in which you wanted to identify
the optimum policy
right so they're they're agnostic
learning where you don't assume the
hypothesis class
captures any information about the
distribution there are also
other assumptions that you can make such
as realizability
and more assumptions to make the
problems more tractable
so um so so that allows us to take some
lessons from statistical learning theory
that um like which which says that it
suffices to
uh run empirical risk minimization it is
sufficient and necessary to use
empirical risk minimization and any
learnable problems are also learnable
with with
erm or asymptotic drm in the context of
rl this
is saying that we can we can simply
design some kind of estimator
we had pi some kind of ope estimator and
then just do exhaustive
search right so so how you implement
this arc
max is out of the picture but we're
interested in the statistical property
of such erm estimator which
seems to suggest that we can simply
evaluate pi
and also evaluate pi hat uh that that
comes out of the the
this this erm and that gives us the two
epsilon upper bound of uh
uh of of the sub-optimality
of offline learn so so we we
since this is a theory group and from
the statistic learning 101 we all know
that that this is a flawed argument
because pi uh pi hat is data dependent
uh so what you really need
is a so-called uniform convergence so if
we we are able to add
um just an additional thing at a
supremum over a family
uh of policies so the high probability
holds
um like simultaneously over all policies
within this policy class and this
argument
this argument works and then we can use
uniform
ope to derive the offline learning bond
we said the advantage being that this is
algorithm
independent so you can use any algorithm
that optimizes the empirical objective
and and and that will give you like the
same bond uh i
mean for offline learning uh relative to
the
to the uniform of offline policy
batteries
all right so so there are some blow up
in the parameters in terms of the sample
complexity um so from the standard
statistical learning so this is
typically given by some complexity
measure d
right so this could be uh the number of
parameters or more generally vc
dimension or the metric entropy
and then for finite policy class so so
like usually this is very uh this is
relatively on the same order of the
log of the cardinality of the of the
function class
um you can also use red marker
complexity to derive such
such uniform convergence okay
um that risk is an interesting question
so what is a natural complexity measure
for the policy classes that's commonly
used in reinforcement learning so today
i'm going to
uh give like some preliminary result on
this
of this problem on the the standard
tabular
mdp set okay so
um a short summary of our key
contribution on the two problems
um on on the problem of point wise uh
offline policy evaluation so our results
say that
um you can you can you can solve this
problem where analyze the mean square
error with this completely hidden
looking expression so if we simplify
this a little bit
um well so it scales with h squared over
uh uh h squared over n uh undm
so ndm is the like so so
so so dm is uh in the best possible
scenario is
relatively on the other one over sa so
uh so you can you can see like uh
at least two more interpretive one um
and and one thing i wanted to
to also point out is the leading term in
this expression is also the the primary
lower bound so essentially uh we have
completely solved the
the at least asymptotically the ope
problem the point wise op problem
because it matches um the lower bound
for every
um pi meal and mdp pair uh md
mdp triplets on the other hand
for the uniform ope we we've derived a
set of
results that allows us to show that
if we just use a model based estimator
and then
plug in the estimator to estimate the
empirical mdp
and then say use the value iteration of
policy iteration to find the
optimal policy then this then this erm
obeys a strong property so that it
achieves a simple complexity bond um
error rate that was a just a blow up of
a factor of h in the
uh in the square root and and and we
also showed that this quantity
is information theoretically optimal
okay so that's a summary of the result
uh
so so i won't go into the details of the
the prior results so
um but there there are a long line of
work on both problems
um more on the offline policy evaluation
with the
the the first work of such starting from
the standard simulation lemma
uh but but you see that we've made some
substantial improvement
over the parameters and and end up
reaching the optimal
optimal result the the one thing that i
wanted to point out is that the
same result is also implied by uh by
monday's work
um that focus on linear mdp but it
implies
uh the optimal sample complexity with
high probability of the same outer
and they are also for instance optimal
for the problem of offline policy
learning the picture is a little bit
more complicated
because we don't really have um a good
comparator
um on on the same setting um so the
closest to us
is the work of xi'an zhang which deals
with the infinite horizon setting but
if we translate the result to our
setting uh then then um
they they they get an additional
dependence on
h on on the planning horizon um
so so the concrete comparison is really
the simulation lemma
because the simulation lemma is actually
a uniform convergence bond rather than a
point wise conversion spawn
although like it suffers a deficiency of
a
factor of blow up on h square uh h times
s
square okay so so they're also com
comparisons with respect to
um to settings that assumes a generative
model which is more well studied
um we've actually learned um
some useful techniques from this
literature to derive our
um tight bond um so so we can see that
there are some improvement over
over these approaches as well so um so
there are
methods specific uh algorithms um these
bonds apply to specific algorithms and
they're
also like like similar uniform
conversions type of bonds that applies
to all uh
methods that gives you the nearly
empirically optimal uh policy so this
epsilon opt is the optimization error
so if you run your algorithm forever
then you can get uh
you you can get this to zero um but uh
um well we we made some improvement over
the
the tightest bond in the generated model
setting as well
okay so that's that's a summary of our
uh main contributions
uh so um i um
i guess our our result is the first has
achieved optimal rates in the offline
setting
and and there's a matching lower bound
that we proved which explicitly
depends on the the exploration parameter
uh dm
um so so the construction is um
like takes a few clever thoughts but but
this is more or less
the the same construction from before um
tailored for this particular setup okay
right and and and um we've we've come up
with uh
examples to demonstrate that that this
hq
is really the right scaling so what this
is saying is that uh if we want to
answer the question
is that what is the right complexity
measure for um
for reinforcement learning problem for
offline reinforcement learning problems
and then that quantity d
is really the planning horizon age under
our model
so this is an interesting observation
because uh well um
like like usually we like in the
previous talk uh we we consider
the policy class or the the family of
finite family of value functions um and
then
it is typically considered that the log
of the cardinality
of the of the policy class is the right
object to achieve
but at least in this case if we use use
a union bond
this will give us additional dependence
uh factor of h
uh a factor of s um but but our lower
bound actually expect
that that we don't we shouldn't really
depend on the the size of the state
space
okay so um and and mo if we use most
standard techniques to deal with this
problem will end up leading
leading us to something similar to
simulation lemma which have additional
dependence on hns and so on
the the the part of reason why the
dependence on h
is tricky even for the pointwise
estimation problem is because
say if we look at this uh primary raw
lower bound
um so so it so it's a summation of h
quantities that can be as large as
in every in every every item so if we
sum this up
so we somehow magically get a square
rather than
uh um so so this is on the this this is
typically on the order of uh
h square so we're summing um like
h h items uh with the maximum value
being h squared
but we magically end up getting it
getting h squared uh without blowing up
over the summation
so so this is sometimes handled by the
law of total variance and
and and there's acute proof that that
for the for the offline and of policy
case like in our previous paper at the
end stats
all right so so so now let's get to
to the uniform convergence and how we
actually get um the
of offline policy optimization bonds so
we consider
three families of policies um the family
of all policies
that applies to this problem and the
family of all deterministic policy
and and finally we consider a local uh
policy class called
ipsilon opt empirically optimal policy
pi hack
which says that the value of this policy
uh um is close to the empirically
optimal
uh policy so by empirical it means that
we are evaluating this quantity
according to
the empirically estimated mdp rather
than the unknown
um like true mvp that generates the data
okay so so so if we can solve the
problem with
even the narrowest class with uniform
convergence that that implies an offline
learning bond with the same
with us with the same error rate okay
so for the global uniform convergence
for our policy so this is what we
end up getting um so so we get a result
that that has a rate dependence on n and
dm
um but uh their blow up factor of h
here um and a blow up on the factor of
hs
on on the second term but but notice
that there isn't a
log one over delta so when delta is
extremely small
then we can subsume this into the bond
and then we get something that that's
only a factor of h away from from being
optimal
okay so um so i won't bore you with the
details it requires
uh some martingale decomposition and a
lot of statistical tricks
to and concentration and and rather
matter complexity argument
and application of market arm inequality
to
to to get this bound um so so for the
family of our deterministic policies
um and using a similar technique before
we can or just directly using among this
work uh we can
apply union bound to the high
probability of policy evaluation bond
which gives us a blow up of hs
over the h h square uh point wise
convergence fund
but but this bond is sub-optimal by a
biofactor of h
so finally uh if we consider a family of
empirical linear optimal policies
specified by this policy class
then then there are some tricks that we
can use to
to somehow like decouple the dependence
between the past and the future
by after conditioning on the number of
uh
um like state action visitations that we
observe at any given moment and that
allows us to
to uh to derive a conditional version of
the of the second like tricky issue
that we just discussed earlier that sums
up
uh uh that sum up sums up the
conditional variances
into into h square without uh
introducing additional dependence on h
and that saves another factor of h and
and which leads to
the bonds that matches the information
theoretic limit
okay so um so so that's the three of our
um like uniform convergence serums um
so so i i like really won't have time to
talk about this uh these techniques in
the proof
but some of them might be applicable to
to problems that you are uh working on
for both offline rl and online rl
uh we have a marketing goal
decomposition of those of the era
of the empirical era um that that
have two forms both primo and dual we
have a fictitious estimator technique
that
allows us to to um to deal with the
tricky dependencies that that's given by
uh
the offline setting rather than the
generative model setting
um and and um the idea of anchoring
around the empirical optimal policy
after taking a difference of the
empirical estimated
uh belmont equation and the true bellman
equation so
this idea is coming from uh um um
like uh agawa kakade and yan uh
and and uh and
and and young and uh well and we've made
some improvement to this technique that
that allows us to
uh to apply this to our problem and
achieve a better dependence on certain
parameters
okay so um so so for people who are
interested in
you can ask me offline or just look at
the paper
okay so to research the main point uh
we've uh derived
uniform com point wise and uniform
convergence results for the offline
evaluation
problem for the off for the pointwise
problem we
have a obtained in in some sense the
best
point like for instance optimal results
after all
other terms and for the uniform
convergence result we've derived the
rate
optimal uh bond that that satisfies this
for all practical
uh reasons of of policy optimization for
identifying the optimum policy
um and getting these tight dependence on
all the parameters uh is non-trivial and
some of the proof techniques might be
generalizable
to other settings as well okay so
um i'd like to conclude the talk by uh
stating a few open problems so first of
all
um like even in this very restrictive
setting
of tabular mvp the rate of global
uniform convergence is still unknown
right so our conjecture is that it is um
as expected as the same as our lower
bound
but there are technical issues in
actually deriving this
and we're actively working on that um
there are some promising leads but but
i still think that that we need some
additional um like new insight
to to completely solve this problem and
and
um well um it's natural to think about
what is the natural complexity measure
beyond the tabular case
and and say for the policy classes uh
such as the softmac policy for
those that are natural for proximal uh
policy iterations and so on
and and to generalize this problem to
functional approximation because uh
if we really want to apply um
reinforcement learning to real-life
applications it's important
it is important for us to to to get
efficient algorithms
um which means that uh
like including handling the implicit
dependence on all the parameters of the
problem that's hidden within the policy
class
um the the the the log of the
cardinality class
okay thank you very much for your
attention and and here are the papers
great thank you very solid work so i i
follow both yusuf and nen's work very
closely and i think that this set of
results are very strong
and certainly i think like being able to
make the connection
between important assembly and making
the optimal this is definitely a
non-trivial contribution
and set the tone for a lot of follow-up
works
so thank you so do we have any question
for yusha and then
so there was a question in the q and a
from chava
i think that's question to nan maybe uh
nan do you wanna
uh shall we start with uh questions
since he still has
slides here i think chandra and amir
massoud both have questions for him
oh sorry i uh where's these questions i
said they're in qa in qa oh i see sorry
i didn't see it yeah i'll just let
people grill yourself first and then
forget about my talk
okay uh train trend right can you speak
sorry i didn't see your question earlier
uh yeah i'm
i'm looking at it so so trenton's
question is what does near empirically
optimal mean yeah sorry i should have
explained that more clearly it means
that it is
empirically optimal with respect to the
estimated empirical mdp
right we are taking a model-based
approach
and and um for the next question so the
bond of the policy class is nearly
optimal with respect to empirical
optimal reminds me of local red metal
complexity and the pitting argument in
the empirical process
theory like have you used any of these
techniques um
do we really need a global uniform
convergence as opposed to the focusing
on the policies that are more promising
right a very interesting question so um
so so the the first question are we
using local uh
rather mathematical complexities and
pinning arguments uh
not not really um like
on top of my head i don't see how they
are directly applicable here
uh but but certainly we can look closer
look
more closely into this um and do we
really need a global uniform convergence
i guess from a policy optimization point
of view like not really
um on the other hand like in the offline
uh
in offline learning in practice uh
typically we don't expect to get to the
global optimal solution like
one shot right so what we can hope to do
is to maybe improve the policy a little
bit so there are
many heuristic algorithm and and the
evaluation functions
that are heuristics that you can use to
solve the planning problem
so so i i think it is still important to
um to to to allow global uniform
convergence and it will be great if it
has the same rate
um in a sense that then that will allow
any heuristic message for you to
to run and then what you see on the
empirical estimated mbdp is going to be
what you get
on the population that one
all right yeah i guess if there are no
further questions i
uh i'll just uh
pass the mic to an end
i'm only like uh i thought you wanted me
to clarify some questions from chava but
we had a somewhat long conversation in
there i don't know
if there are any particular parts yeah i
thought that's a the
even the first question this is good
right because because like
it's it's easy to think that state
aggregation in q-star
is similar to linear mdp but it's
actually
yeah general saturate so would you like
just explain it yeah
yeah so yeah actually i'm not sure
what's the
the best uh the sharpest message here
but uh
i think java is trying to draw actually
i'm sorry java is trying to draw a
connection between state aggregation and
linear mdps but i think
uh first the state aggregation within
itself there are many versions
uh and also i think none of the versions
correspond to exactly linear ndp
for example as i put in the chat the
um by simulation is uh sort of like
different linear mdb says that your
transformations have a low rank
factorization but by simulation uh when
your problem has a non-trivial bison
modulation
that's not necessarily true that's first
and second
in my work i didn't use biosimulation i
only used the q-star relevant
abstraction
and as i showed in the size for any
arbitrary mdp
even if your low rank uh your transition
matrix has like
ridiculously like where structures
the complexity q star relevant
abstraction always exists
so i think they're related but they're
not they're not
that they're not the same thing yeah
okay uh thank you i think we have to let
you go
all right uh uh let's thank ishan and
now again for the wonderful talks and uh
they're very strong results and uh well
appreciate that you present them
clearly in our workshop thank you
so i hope to see you again on in the
morning tomorrow
and so that's all thank you all for
participating